ces terres qui m'obsède de jour et nuit
c'est un départ n'est devant des
millions de touristes ça et chaque année
paris et sa plus célèbre but messi
l'incontournable montmartre se visitent
le vrai montmartre le se dévoile casser
plus attentifs promeneurs ramanda c'est
une butte un petit peu clandestine c'est
un peu la fda de paris neuf dixièmes en
dessous un dixième au dessus on ne
connaît que la face apparente de ces
différents versants ceci dit la réalité
est tout autre et elle montre le
présente beaucoup de choses que fait
étonnant étonnantes comme le manoir
néogothique de l'original compte de
l'escale au pied construite au 19e
siècle et niché au fond d'une impasse
la bâtisse se dérobe toujours vos
circuits touristiques
plus haut les deux derniers moulins de
la butte surplombant la rue lepic
le moulin de la galette immortalisé par
renoir est un des fils qui nous ramène
au temps où on marque ce n'était qu'un
village avec ses secrets et ses
croyances qui ne se dévoile qu'au détour
des chemins de traverse
montmartre est un village avec avec ses
légendes et on a une légende qui
partiront intéressante ici avec ce
rocher que certains montmartrois appelle
le rocher de la sorcière qui présente de
grosses pierres qui semble bloqué le
chemin et que personne n'a jamais touché
parce qu on raconte que si quelqu'un
venait à déplacer cette pierre est bien
il y aurait une catastrophe sur mon mars
alors on ne sait pas si c'est vrai ou
pas mon prend pas de risques sont là les
stalles finale et andres le doute sur
vient et on tout dire là où peut-être ou
transportés dans un coquet quartier
londonien
il me fait le coup du souviens-toi
madame de retour avenue junot plus de
doute
des gamins de pariente encore la maison
de leurs auteurs poulbot voisine de
celle de tristan tzara le fondateur du
dadaïsme picasso mac orlan utrillo
dorgelès et tous les autres tous ceux
qui trouvèrent leur muse à montmartre
ils y ont laissé un peu de leur âme
avec des souvenirs sur les bras
d'autres y ont même perdu la tête de la
police en dhr 1 qui abritait autrefois
un asile d'aliénés et parmi les autres
passions il y avait gérard de nerval qui
avait l'habitude assez comique de
balader au jardin du luxembourg avec un
homard vivant tenus en laisse
à la folie sandrin on est tout près du
sommet alors petit détour par la place
du tertre derrière sa façade xviiie
saint pierre est une des plus vieilles
églises parisiennes
édifié dans le style roman sur les
ruines d'un temple de mercure
avant de reprendre le métro petit coup
d'oeil à saint jean des briques qui fait
de béton armé de briques rouges défraya
la chronique en son temps comme
d'ailleurs les stations art nouveau
guima dont la baisse est l'un des deux
derniers exemplaires couvert montmartre
est comme ça elle innove et concerts
mails insolites et le bo à portée de
toutes les curiosités